il est environ 18 heures ce mercredi
lorsque les agents de la brigade
intérieure des douanes de tours repères
sur l'a10 au nord du péage de sorigny un
poids lourd provenant d'espagne
plusieurs indices nous ont amenés à
faire un contrôle approfondi notamment
le un vif intérêt de la part de notre
chien qui était très excitée aux abords
du camion
donc on a monté dans le la cargaison
comme on fait régulièrement et là
plusieurs endroits il a il a marqué ce
qu'on appelle marquer yg rate
en général quand il ya des odeurs qui
l'intéressent et l'issue de ce marquage
donc on a procédé à un contrôle
approfondi par
un dépotage des marchandises qu'ils
étaient des carottes conditionnés dans
des sacs de 10 à 20 kg et on s'est rendu
compte très vite que à l'intérieur de
ces palettes une cheminée avait été créé
avec à l'intérieur des produits
stupéfiants
la résine de cannabis à la clé deux
tonnes 160 de cannabis la plus grosses
saisies de l'histoire de la brigade de
tours mais pour elle le plus intéressant
c'est la suite qui sera donnée à cette
intervention
c'était donc arizant qui était destinée
au marché français
ce qui est quand même assez rare sur
l'autoroute a10 où nous avons plutôt
tendance à avoir des prises qui sont
destinés à l'angleterre donc avec d un
déroulement qui est beaucoup plus
délicat à gérer
alors que là
donc nos services de police vont pouvoir
enquêter et on espère que ça mettra bas
ont certes un réseau de trafic de
stupéfiants
la police judiciaire va donc à présent
enquêter sur cette affaire
le conducteur du poids lourd un italien
âgé de 58 ans risque une amende
équivalente à la valeur des stupéfiants
soit plusieurs millions d'euros et des
années de prison